It is now 24 hours
since the already-legendary
Trump-Kim summit.
Frankly, I'm still buzzing,
and not just because
my phone's on silent,
and I have a debt collector
hounding me
about my impounded
flame thrower, no.
No, I'm also buzzing
because there were so many
exciting moments yesterday
that got overshadowed
by Trump's big win.
And here to help me go over
them, citizen journalists,
-Kobi Libii and Aaron Jackson.
-(applause and cheering)
Guys, welcome.
Now that the dust has settled,
we can relax a little
and let our hair down, so...
(sighing)
Ah. That is better. Okay.
Now in a word, how would you
describe the summit yesterday?
I'd say "historic," like
the launch of the Titanic,
but without the shipwreck.
And I'd say
"profoundly emotional,"
like the movie Titanic,
-but without the Billy Zane.
-KLEPPER: Yes.
Now, Kobi, what moment
really stood out to you?
Three words: Dennis Rod Man.
-WOMAN: A very strange twist
in this story. -WOMAN 2: Yes.
WOMAN: So Dennis Rodman arrived,
uh, in Singapore.
I talked to Kim Jong-un,
and, uh,
and administration
over there five years ago.
And he sat down and asked me,
"Hey, Dennis, um,
"I would like
to ask you three things.
"If you could go back to the
president of the United States
these three things, and I would
be willing to talk to him."
And Obama didn't even give me
the time of day!
(scoffs) He didn't give
Dennis Rodman the time of day!
Obama wasted months
talking to experts
on the history
of the Korean Peninsula.
Dennis Rodman could have given
him 45 breathtaking minutes
about the time he and Kim went
go-karting over peasants.
Now, in spite of Dennis Rodman's
obvious expertise,
I know what you're thinking:
Why would Trump bring an NBA
player with him to Singapore?
Answer: He didn't.
Dennis Rodman's trip
was actually sponsored
by a cryptocurrency company
called PotCoin.
(laughter)
Here's Dennis Rodman walking
with either a senior executive
from the company
or Turtle from Entourage.
-(laughter) -I'm glad you
brought this up, Kobi.
So, what is PotCoin?
PotCoin is a cryptocurrency
specifically designed
to buy and sell marijuana.
Not to be confused with CoinPot,
the jar where I keep my change,
which so far
only has one investor.
(laughter)
-Is it...
-It's me.
-It's you, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I'm the investor.
And to be clear,
we are still talking
about the North Korea summit.
Believe it or not, we are.
You see,
even though PotCoin paid
for Dennis Rodman's trip
to Singapore,
Trump valued his contribution
so much that Dennis Rodman
got a White House
thank-you call.
(chuckles):
Which makes sense,
because Republicans have
a long tradition
of including NBA players
in diplomacy.
When Reagan
visited Berlin in '87,
you know who was
right there beside him?
-Boston Celtic Kevin McHale.
-Yes.
Oh. I believe
the famous quote is,
"Mr. Gorbachev,
tear down this wall.
"And, Mr. McHale,
I can see your scrotum
dipping out from those shorts."
-Can I just add something?
-Yeah.
First of all, great summary.
I didn't understand
a word of it.
But personally,
I'm more interested
in the human aspect
of this thing.
-Okay, the human rights aspect?
-No, the human interest aspect.
The heart, the drama,
and Dennis Rodman's
emotional thank-yous.
-Can I thank some people?
-Yeah, go ahead.
But let me ask you something,
don't go on a whole tour
about it.
Oh, my God.
So moving.
I'm not exactly sure
what he's talking about, or why,
but it feels like
he just won a championship
or an Oscar.
And Pearl Jam
is somehow involved?
I mean, (bleep).
I love North Korea now!
(laughter, applause, whooping)
I...
I heard Jeremy spoke
at the summit today.
Okay, no one actually knows
Pearl Jam references, Jordan.
But... you know who really
lit up hearts this weekend?
Ivanka.
In response to her daddy's
critics, Ivanka tweeted...
Incredible.
Ivanka's tweets pack
all the inspirational punch
of a wrist tattoo that says,
"Just breathe."
(laughter)
And to be honest,
I'm pretty impressed
that she knows
a Chinese proverb.
Well, admittedly, I guess...
And, in fact...
-(laughter)
-But...
who knows more
about Chinese culture,
actual Chinese people
or Ivanka,
whose clothing line
was once manufactured
in factories
where real Chinese people
claimed they
were actually abused?
Oh. Amen.
Gents, but we need
to wrap this up, so real quick,
what do you hope to see
in future Trump-Kim summits?
Less research, more CoinPot...
Sorry, PotCoin.
-Yes.
-And I'll just say nine words:
Eric Trump haiku, baby.
Amazing work as always, guys.
The fight continues.